hi my name is danica Rajan I am an
assistant professor in the department of
neuroscience and the Friedman brain
Institute in the Icahn School of
Medicine at Mount Sinai I'm a
computational neuroscientist and today
I'm going to be talking about new work
in my lab that I'm very excited about
it's it's funded mainly through the
brain initiative and the National
Institutes of Health the title of my
talk is multi region network of networks
models of adaptive and maladaptive state
transitions and before I get into the
meat of my talk I'd like to you know
thank my colleagues and collaborators on
the project most of the heavy lifting on
this project is currently being done by
Ned Perry a postdoc in my lab the
experimental data was provided by Tyler
benster and Fernando men in the
colonizer Ross lab Camille Spencer
Salman is a rock star grad student also
in my lab and gene Carter I would like
to thank also for their contributions to
this project I would also like to thank
our funding sources primarily the brain
initiative which has been which you know
and we thank them for their faith in our
work okay so in life behaviors or you
know we constantly evaluate whether you
know we constantly evaluate whether the
actions that we're about to perform are
worth the effort we expend in performing
these actions right and so you know
every decision we make involves
evaluating among these actions for you
know their their worthiness
now if actions repeatedly fail to yield
fruit or a repeatedly fruitless then you
become you know disappoint this is you
know just and in the extreme this can
manifest as hopelessness
so the maladaptive state of discounting
actions or considering them all
fruitless because they've constantly
been fruitless
perhaps through experience is you know
it is hopelessness and hopelessness is
one of the hallmarks of clinical
depression and you will see that trend
continuing throughout my talk
now hopelessness is seen in many animals
and across diverse nervous systems with
various architect personal complexity as
well as different kinds of sampling so
here are some experiments primarily done
in rodents which is called a forced swim
paradigm in which a room is placed in a
in a small jar of water with no perch
for it to get on so initially it tries
to escape this adverse scenario by
swimming vigorously trying to escape
this and then eventually it gives up and
doesn't swim as vigorously anymore so
the initial phase when it swims
vigorously to avoid the strenuous or
stressful experience is called active
coping and later on when the animals
looks as though it has given up and
reduces its movement away from this
adverse and you know this type worse
situation is called passive coping now
active and passive coping lie on two
ends of a behavioral spectrum and so it
is exactly this type of transition
between active coping and passive coping
that I'm going to be talking about from
a theoretical perspective and so you
know if passive coping occurs earlier
than normal then you know it's a
maladaptive condition and you know
interventions have been shown to dilate
the onset of passive coping now as I
mentioned most of this you know study of
passive coping has been studied in rooms
and so Mouse neurobiology is a very fast
there's a vast literature on Mouse
neurobiology in passive coping and in
similar states and so here's a little
list of a few papers that aren't that
fun subject and what I would like to
highlight here is these two regions
once the habenula and once the raphe and
i'd like to you know like you to put a
pin in this thought because we're gonna
return to these regions over and over
again now Mouse neurobiology is very
complex and even with current neuro
technological advances we can only
access a very small fraction which you
know leads to partial sampling issues so
enter a nervous system with more access
namely the new Arvold zebrafish and a
lot of zebrafish not only provides
unprecedented access to potentially
every neuron in its brain but its
nervous system has homologies with the
mammalian system primarily again if you
notice in the slide in this in the
schematic you can see there have been
ill and the rat they highlighted both in
the fish at the top and the mammalian
system at the bottom and there's a few
papers also including from our
collaborators labs studying you know the
larval zebrafish is an exquisite
experimental system with enormous access
so one of the questions a big question
that my lab is interested in almost like
a research program is are there any
circuit mechanisms that are conserved
when you go from from a smaller nervous
system to a larger nervous system and
which ones which of these circuit
mechanisms are different when you go
from you know a smaller nervous system
through a larger nervous system let's
say from larvae zebrafish to grown to
macaques to even humans these are very
interesting directions but for the
purposes of today's talk I would like to
narrow this question down to just this
one namely what certainly changes
mediate the state transition from active
to passive köppen in the larval
zebrafish and so together this question
I turned to experiments again so these
are experiments that were designed by
Erin Andelman in the die strasse lab and
he designed a stress paradigm or a
behavioral challenge Erinn I'm for this
model system so larva zebrafish are
exposed to roughly one Hertz week
electrical shocks so initially when the
shock comes on as you see in this little
schematic here the fish you know
vigorously whip their tails and try to
get away from the stressful stimulus
this should remind you a little bit of
the active coping phase now these
stresses don't stop coming just because
the fish with its tail so in other words
it's persistent and it's inescapable so
eventually over a period of about a
half-hour so in this behavioral
challenge period larval zebrafish that
were previously actively coping now
lapse into passive coping or roughly
immobile state now in the Nazareth lab
technological advances are enable us to
have access to the real-time
tail trajectories tracked on a
moment-by-moment basis throughout the
experience and that's and the result of
that monitoring is plotted here so here
on the y axis is the is movements
averaged across different cohorts of
fish plotted as a function of time in
the experiment in black you should see
control that is the average of the tail
movements of the control fish and in
blue the shocked fish and you can see
that in the initial periods of the shock
which are highlighted in this very faint
pink bar here that the shocked fish
exhibit an enhancement in the tail
movements as if to avoid the adversity
and that is the act of coping phase
eventually however when the stress is
persistent and inescapable you can see
that they that the movement of the shock
fish dropped well below the 1/3 of the
control fish eventually ceasing and
that's what you see in the second part
of the experiment here or passive coping
so it's these two behavioral transitions
that I'm interested in understanding the
mechanisms of so experiments here are
not only limited to the behavioral
readout but also cellular resolution
monitoring of the entire brain of the
larval zebrafish
so they've expressed nuclear localized
gcamp which means that every ry that
you'll see in a video that I'll show you
in a second it is really a neuron so
they can image from between ten thousand
to forty thousand neurons per fish
during the entire experiential state
while also tracking its behavior so this
is quite an exquisite dataset and this
is sort of what one of the stills from
the video looks like and so if we may
come up for that I can show the audience
what what do you know these videos of
these larval zebrafish look like while
they're being imaged
so at the so this is a still from the
same video that you saw before the
bottom part of the slide is the exact
same schematic a simplified schematic of
the experiment paradigm showing the
stresses building up in the fish lapsing
from active coping to passive coping and
on the top left you see the averages of
the average tail movement across these
core parts of fish okay so looking at
these types of activity patterns Erin
did you know Erin did a lot of clever
clustering of these types of all titles
two features popped out of the order
just the measurements alone and those
are as follows the first main Norrell
finding or finding from the population
activity from the experimental data was
that as the stress has built up the
activity in the heaven ela seems to ramp
up so what do you see here on the
extreme left is you know a mattock of
the fish with the with the habenula
highlighted and you see the average
activity or the Delta F overtly over F
averaged over all of the fish plotted as
a function of time in black again is
control and in blue is the shoc and you
can see that in the in the end and you
can see that you know in the habenula
the activity seems to rise steadily
throughout the experiment and the dashed
line and zero is the time at which the
first shot came on so now if you d
couple your eyeballs a little bit you
can sort of imagine that there's like a
little phase going on in the beginning
part of the habenula activation there's
a little bump maybe and then if there's
the steady ramping of activity but you
know there that's the first finding the
second finding from the experiment alone
was that there's a suppression of
activity in the Rafic now remember I
told you the beginning of the talk that
they have been yolanda Rafi are gonna be
the linchpins around which the around
which the talk is its organized and so
so they find activity in the Rafi again
this is the average Delta F over F for
all of the fish zero marks the time of
the onset of the shocks and the raffia
in the shocked fish seems to be
exhibiting an inhibitory response as
sharks keep building on with
I'd like to return to the question that
I set out in the beginning on the top
which is well what circuit changes
mediate the state transition from active
to passive coping so from measurements
all we knew is that they have been you
know ramped up and the raphe went down
so the mechanisms behind which these two
findings the mechanism underlying these
two findings and then how these two
findings at the whole brain level
influence the behavioral state
transition from active to passive coping
that's what I mean by asking what
circuit changes or mechanisms underlie
this transition and so for that my
approach is going to be to build to
build and then to reverse-engineer
neural network models that are that are
built directly using the time series
measurements from the experiment as
constraints and so what do I mean by
that right so before I get into how I
build these networks and what we'll get
from them basically we get stuff that
are inaccessible for measurements alone
I'd like to take a minute and tell you
the very basics of what goes on in these
networks and how we build them okay so
this is the basic network design and so
this is a rate this is a schematic of a
rate based recurrent neural network or
RNN and I have schematized this so that
each unit is symbolized in the blue
spheres connected by what I hope are
randomly random weights or randomly
initialized and so I have studied
networks like this before in a set of
papers graduate career collaboration
with Larry Abbott and hangs on Polinski
and each unit in networks like this
follows a first-order differential
equation so these networks give you know
a certain mathematical elegance to to
how we formulate the element the basic
building blocks of neural networks in
the brain and so you can understand
everything you need to know about these
networks if you knew the firing rates or
some kind of continuous activity of each
unit and if you knew the weights with
which or the strengths with which each
pair of humans interacted in these
networks and that's kind of what this
equation symbolizes over time so here
I'm just
walk you through very quickly what these
terms are networks like this can exhibit
it can can be exposed to external inputs
I should mention that in our case we
present in you know when I'm building
networks that are similar to the data
that are from a shocked fish then these
external inputs I design will be you
know imagine that they're pulses right
square wave pulses presented with the
exact same timing as the experimenter
presents in the experiment but here I've
just you know symbolize them with with
with with the traces that you see in
orange now what you see here is Phi is
the Fi curve or the activation function
and you can pick your favorite
saturating non-linearity here and the
key thing to note here is that networks
like this their activity is governed by
this matrix which I've called J in the
mathematical equation and I'm calling
them directed interactions here and
these symbolize the strength of the
interaction and the direction of the
interaction between every pair of
neurons in this model network and so if
I were to say every neuron is literally
a neuron and every weight is directly a
synapse then this will collapse into the
synaptic connectivity matrix but I'm
trying to keep this as general as
possible so I'm just gonna call them
directed interactions now I this is a
very basic network design that doesn't
correspond to anything that occurs in
the fish and so I can start networks at
this place by filling or populating this
directive interaction matrix with
elements that are drawn from a Gaussian
distribution that looks like this so
here I've written down the probability
of an of an element as a function of its
strength centered at zero and with a
variance with a variance scaled as this
number G squared over the network sites
and so this is a very basic network
design that I'm gonna take as a starting
point and change in two ways the first I
do is to take networks like this and
this is a schematic of exactly the same
thing that I showed you before a single
region model and the directed
interaction matrix from a it and
I can extend it to symbolize the
interactions within and between two
regions in the brain participation and
model there's two regions here in that
I've symbolized here in the schematic
consequently its directed interaction
matrix becomes slightly more complex so
here you see these two squares along the
block along the diagonal or block
diagonal matrix those symbolize the
strength of the interactions or
directions of the interactions within
each of these regions that are
symbolized as region 1 and region 2 and
the across diagonal elements symbolize
the interactions between these regions
or the inter area projections you can
play this game further potentially to
the whole brain and get a multi region
iron and and here I'm showing in four
out of the possible 15 that we can do
for the larval zebrafish because that's
how many regions that we have access to
data from and for a full region model
like this the directed interaction
matrix acquires an even more complex
structure where again the interactions
within the region are symbolized in the
blocks that you see in going across the
principal diagonal and the interactions
or inter area communication weights are
in the off diagonal elements so that's
the first thing we do we take that first
basic random Network and we add
complexity to it by wiring more of them
together the second thing we do is to
take the activity of each unit in this
model network and train it to match
calcium data directly and so what I'm
doing here is to tell you what I told
you before with how to train these
models but by time series measurements a
priori so that's what I'm trying to tell
you here so so what you see here in red
on the right hand side is the input
current to one unit here and I'm gonna
match it directly to a target which in
this case is gonna be that calcium
activity recorded from that Mulan from
its partner neuron in the experiment in
dataset and the linear difference
between those two quantities will drive
the update for the entire directed
interaction matrix this learning rule is
called recursively squares there's a lot
of foundational work based on this and
for free for the purposes of the fish
what should appear now on the right hand
side of the screen is basically telling
you that I built to start I'm building
networks that are as big as the size of
the experimental data set so if I'm
building a whole brain network with 15
regions interconnected then there'll be
a order 10 to the 4 neurons or model
units in this in this model fish are an
EM that I've built
ok so you know let's say we're we
managed to pull this off right and and
we have done this quite profitably in a
number of papers that you can see here
so we can use this trip to you know
trade networks just to behave or you
know just to match the behavioural data
from real experiments and I've written
papers on that subject we can also train
these networks so that their units
inside match neural dynamics are
empirically observed and I've written
papers on that too including the one
that appeared in 70 ok so you know this
exercise produces a network where the
weights have now been changed so as to
reflect the activity of the experimental
data directly right so what does this
exercise by you do we really have a
system that is as complex as the
original system we set up to set out to
match and what this exercise buys you
are three things that should appear now
the first thing is that a multi-region
RNN model like this once trained will
produce realistic neural dynamics very
similar to that observed experimentally
once the training is stopped so we're
not fitting a curve necessarily what
we're doing is building a dynamical
system that once you set it up in the
initial condition will autonomously
produce the dynamics similar to
experimental data
it lets us infer consistent brain wide
directed interactions which I'm
symbolizing here by this J with a
superscript n tomorrow and so it lets
you infer connectivity both within brain
regions and across brain regions in this
trained connectivity matrix or directed
interaction matrix the third thing you
get which you can't get from X
from measurements alone is that is the
product of the first two which is the
currents or the currents due to the
current connections within and between
regions and so I'm gonna talk about you
know the implications of all this but
let me you know wind this back and show
you the proof of principle in a two
region model so here's a two region
model in which region one is the
habenula region two is the raphe meaning
that the model units in the have been in
the light RN n are trained to match data
from the real habenula of a fish and the
model units in the raphael like RN n are
trained to match the units in the raf a
from the real experiment and they're
both interconnected and so what you see
now at the bottom is the mean squared
error of the learning algorithm as a
function of the number of learning steps
a very standard way of showing that yes
these networks can be trained and this
shows that as learning steps progress
that means where an error goes down and
the network is able to match the data
here's some more evidence of that so I'm
showing you now six example neurons from
the from the habenula at the top and the
raphe at the bottom in all of these
traces data like the real experiment in
Delta F over F is in blue the models
output for that particular neuron is in
red and so the first column is control
fish the second column is is examples
from from an R and n that was trained to
match they different shark fish and you
can see look in these examples at least
that the network does a very good job of
matching the experimental data so now
just to assure you that I didn't
cherry-pick you know these six neurons
in particular we I can also show you
that overall the population dynamics are
also quite faithfully replicated so on
the left now you should see states-based
analysis on top is the control fish and
the bottom is a data from a network that
was trained to match control fish and so
what I'm doing is taking the entire
activity of the habenula rafi or an N in
the bottom and projecting it into the
dominant three of the largest three
principal components at the top and the
data
and at the bottom in the model and you
can see it kind of matches the overall
flavor of the population dynamics this
is true of the control fish as well as
data from from the shocked fish okay so
this works right course it it works
because that's what we're training the
network to do but here's really the key
networks like this we have trained but
we have access to the guts of them so
once you train these artificial networks
to match data like I'm doing here
we can open up the hood and look what's
look at what mechanisms or circuit
motifs drive the activity that you see
once the network is trained so what
these give you the first thing is the
directed interaction matrix right so in
this case it gives you this schematic
that you see here now presynaptic or pre
connections are along the column but the
rows in that's highlighted in red should
be the connections within the habenula
in the block that's highlighted in green
should be the connections within the
Rafa and the across diagonal elements
should be the connections going from and
vanilla to Rafi and Raph it to the
vanilla respectively and so what is the
property the overall property of a
network of the directed interaction
matrix derived from this two region RN
it looks like and that's what I'm
showing you here so I'm taking the
probability density or the or the
histogram then the probability density
of the elements within this entire
matrix and I'm taking the log of it
because the ranges of them were too
large and I'm plotting them as a
function of the interaction strengths so
in gray is the is the matrix from matrix
trained on data from a control fish and
blue is a matrix trained matrix from an
R and then that was trained on data from
sharks fish and already you can see that
in going from control condition to shock
condition this is towards the last part
of the experiment right there's an
expansion in skills now just as a matter
of comparison the very first thing I
showed you was this random initial
matrix that would be a very very small
Gaussian right in the middle
so you can see even the act of training
it on the controlled fish expands its
range but going from control to shocked
fish already has massive expansion in
scales again the y-axis is in Long
movements the main takeaway from this is
that well okay so the meat did not go to
change significantly in going from the
control to the shock fish so we wanted
to attract the other moments of the
probability distribution namely the
standard deviation the kurtosis and the
skewness again skewness wasn't
particularly informative in this case
what this means is that rather than
being rather than being driven by random
connection spread throughout the network
tuning in the habenula graph a you know
double circuit in the brain of the
larval zebrafish appears to be driven by
very few very large synapses which is
what is symbolize which is what
manifests in the in the heavy tailed
nests of these distributions so the
large connections are also the rare ones
and this is a motif that you'll see over
and over again in in the nervous system
of many animals so this is the overall
connectivity of the habenula rafi to
region RNN i want to do see well what
happens if you look at these blocks
independently and here's what we find
the biggest changes come from the have
been EULA so that's what you see here
right so right now I'm splitting the the
connect the overall connectivity matrix
into four blocks and you see the
probability distribution of the one
that's highlighted in red on the top so
again it's log probability density as a
function of interaction strength and you
get the expansion that is here in going
from control to shock is driven a lot by
the but the habenula and it goes in the
right direction in that the heavy allure
connections seem to be strengthened as a
function of the Sharks which again
correlates with the main experimental
finding in the beginning which was that
had been interactivity did seem to ramp
up so perhaps this underlies this
probably points to a mechanism or
probably a consequence of what hap
when they're been dealer activities
ramping probably manifests as a
strengthening of the connections with
individual then we looked at the
connections within the Rafi and okay
there's a very small kind of difference
in going from control to sharp fish goes
in the right direction relative to the
experimental data observed but I wasn't
you know moved to tears by it then we
looked at the connections going from the
habenula to the Rafi which is a known
projection and those did not appear to
be significantly different in going from
the control to the shot but here's the
unexpected response right here's the one
here's the unexpected connection were
finding that the model start out that we
weren't expecting before that there was
also a strengthening of the connections
going from the Rafi back into the
habenula there's only very very little
empirical evidence of there even being
such a connection going from Rafi
feeding back into that Benoit in these
two papers that are listed here but this
is a finding that the model that that we
are now in the process of testing in
collaboration with the dice rock lab in
a set of new optogenetics experiments
which have been designed basically to
test the predictions of a model that we
published in cell and I think the speaks
to one of the state and goals of the
brain initiative is to fund projects
like piece in which the model not only
analyzes existing data and leverages
more than measurement score but then the
models findings could design the next
generation of experiments which will
then recursively modify our model if
needed or falsify its findings so it's
exactly you know this place exactly to
the stated purpose of of the brain
initiative and this finding the
projections from the Raph a to the
habenula and the connections
strengthening within they have been like
those two motifs seem to hold over
multiple fish and so here's you know
five fish from the control condition and
five fish from the shock condition and
I'm showing you the percent changes in
the standard deviation of these of the
probability distributions because as I
mention
the means were not significantly
different and so this was the moment
that we needed to track and so again
here you should see that the top two
which are the within habenula and the
Rafa two have been in our projections
seem to be strengthened in going from
the control condition to the shock
condition so this is like the first part
of my talk you know we have access you
know 15 in regions in the larval
zebrafish right and so this is the kind
of analysis that we can do for any
pairwise combination of out of those 15
but we wanted to say well what else can
we do right can we rule out the impact
of let's say common inputs into the
habenula graphene Network you know so
the mental model that we were working
with originaly was that okay the shocks
come in the habenula says bad stuffs
happening ramps up its activity Rafa
says okay Cavalry's here
worry no more then if the serotonin dump
from the rapid did not make you feel
better then someone had to shut the
movement down now it's in so in front
limbic cortex which is a part of the
prefrontal cortex is implicated in
mammalian systems to be the mediator
that shuts down movement when learned
helplessness or an our case passive
coping it is meant to take place and so
one of the goals for us was to say okay
can we find an infra limbic cortex like
region out of the 15 in the larval
zebrafish and so I'm gonna already tell
you that we went so our findings are not
exactly in line with this hypothesis but
you know it's lettuce in a in a in a
very very interesting direction
nonetheless so we wanted to extend what
we've done so far and add telencephalon
to this and telencephalon was one of the
nodes in the dataset with a large number
of units so this would you know
potentially give us the opportunity to
disentangle the role of common inputs
when you're trying to figure out
connectivity and directionality between
these two regions as well as probably
give us a lead into what could be
playing the role
of an infra limnic like movement
shutdown region and so we did exactly
the same thing as I told you before
except now with the three region neural
network model and each unit was now
matched to a target function either from
the habenula or the Rafah or the
telencephalon depending on which which
network which network was it was meant
to replicate in the real brain of the
lab in zebrafish so again just like
before this exercise will give you
dynamics that was similar to data once
it was trained it will also give you
directed interactions inside the train
matrix except now it would have
connections within the habenula the
raphe and the telencephalon going along
the diagonal and across the two
diagonals will be the pairwise
connections between these regions or
inter area communication principles and
yes we have done the analysis like I've
shown you before where we've tracked the
different moments over the experiment
but I'm gonna tell you you know sort of
almost the direction that were really
the most excited about in this which is
product of the chip so the product of
the two gives you the following right so
this is again the exact same scan I
think that you saw before it gives you
the recurrent currents right so after
matching calcium data a network like
this as I have said before gives you
activations that are similar and here
are stigmatized the directed interaction
matrix here now the dark product of
those two objects gives you currents
will the network due to the recurrent
interactions and if you recall the math
from a few slides ago it's exactly that
second term on the right hand side of
the differential equation which is a dot
product of this matrix J with the
activations across the network and you
can sum these over different indices and
and that's sort of where we're building
to so let's so this lets us look at
currents from the same or from different
areas so for example by looking at the
just the connections within the by you
know looking at the dot product of just
the weights within this habenula network
which are which are now circled in this
in this you know orange square I can
look at you know what are the effects of
the recurrent connections within the
habenula on an example have Benjamin
Mehran I can do the exact same thing by
looking at what are the connections you
know what are the recurrent effects or
the currents from the Rafa into the
habenula and what are the recurrent
currents from the telencephalon into the
habenula and that's what this kinematic
tells you right so this is exactly the
same thing as I've shown you before
except I have not pictorially depicted
the the you know the dot product and I'm
gonna look at everything from the
perspective of the habenula
so in in the orange square is the
habenula to have been Euler connection
if I restrict the rank if I restrict the
the Sun I can only look at the
connections from the Rafa into the
habenula
and if I respect the some another way I
can look at the current currents flowing
from the teen encephalon didn't happen
we can also do this exercise for the RAF
the end for the telencephalon but for
the purposes of the talk let me just
show you what happens if you look at
these currents separately and this is
what the habenula habenula currents look
like so this is an example of the
currents of 12 about 2200 habenula
neurons in a shocked fish which you can
tell because i put the times of the
shocks in the red dots at top and and
this is over time and these habenula
neurons have been sorted by mont eric by
the time at which each peaks along its
row and they've also been normalized by
the mean over the entire over this
entire dataset now you can also look at
the raf a to have been Yin or currents
now the neurons have been ordered in
exactly the same order as they were in
the habenula to have been in the
connections and now this is the
telencephalon to habenula currents and
and you know you can sort of make you
bitwise some sort of activity pattern as
a function of the sorting but what I'm
telling you now is rather than looking
at the activity along the raw activity
of the Hobart
which is what you get from looking at
measurements or by our as a function of
the outputs of our RN ends now we can
decompose this activity into its
component recurrent currents both within
the region last I'm showing you the
habenula vanilla or between regions like
the current flow from the raft into the
heaven Allah or the telencephalon it did
happen and now we can do exactly the
same types of dimensionality reduction
that we would have done on the
activities and my postdoc map eric has
written several papers on the subject
and doesn't built on foundational work
from many labs and so you know if you
did a dimensionality reduction on these
three currents now instead of the
overall activity you're left with these
three axes so in green is the raf into
heaven illa the oranges have been you
two have been EULA and in purple is the
telencephalon to heaven now we can take
the activity and project it into the
space spanned by these three curves and
that's what this looks like so now this
is the overall trajectory of a shock
fish's dynamics population dynamics
projected into the space spanned by
these three axes
we have also overlaid the times of the
times at which the sharks appear in the
real experiment on top of this trace and
immediately something pops up which is
that in the early part of the shocks as
symbolized V they are symbolized by the
warm colors contrary to what we were
expecting the raphe to the habenula
currents seem to be changing a lot which
is evidenced by the trajectory
populating only that subspace it's only
later in the experiment as evidenced by
the late shocks in the colder colors
that the habenula have Angela and the
telencephalon to the habenula subspaces
are populated so we went in looking for
connections within the habenula or they
have annular to habenula currents to be
strengthened but those don't seem to be
coming on line until the late shock
period in fact the early part of the
sharks are driven by currents going from
the raphe to the heaven and so this kind
of look at this kind
approach of looking at manifolds that
are spanning input currents as opposed
to looking at just the outputs that you
can get from measurements alone can help
us now two separate things like time
scales not just sources of these curves
in the network and we're starting to say
okay maybe the early part could
correlate with the active coping phase
as you see in the behavioral diagram
that should appear on the right now in
the first half and and the later later
part or the onset passivity could be
driven by habenula to have been aligned
telencephalon event
engagement or currents flowing in so not
only are these able to deem Ickx or
source separate input currents but they
could actually reveal interesting inter
area effects such as you know
differential engagements of these curves
or timing or two distinct time scales in
this particular case we're now in the
process of proving that this type of
visualization is more informative than
either looking at just the activity of
the habenula neurons which is what you
see here this is the Delta and this is
the activity of the habenula neurons
over time in the middle of the bottom
part of the slide is the averaged
population activity that you've already
seen before this is averaged over the
fish and and and finally you should see
the activity of the habenula neurons or
the measurements that are now projected
into the three dominant principal
components and so you know you know the
time scales are much more mixed or
multiplexed in the traditional view now
to really drive this point home we
wanted to look at these look at what
these principal components actually look
like over time and so that's what you
see here the top part of the slide is
identical to what you saw before and so
right and so now here's an example
control fish and I've plotted the
normalized current or the first
principal component as a function of
time in the experiment the movements
that you see here in the gray are the
tail whips that have now been controlled
with now set so as to just give you a
visual indication
of the fact that you know the control
fish just keep wagging their tail for
the duration of the entire experiment
and you see that the rapid to habenula
in green habenula to heaven illa in
orange and teal and Cephalon to habenula
in purple the three sort of mirror each
other they're not you know they're not
separated now you contrast that with the
exact same plot but now plotted based on
activity based on activity from a
network that was trained on data from a
shot fish with the shock times again
early and late shots in the dots at the
top and again now you see something very
interesting happen which is that the
rapid to the habenula seems to be
mediating mediating the active coping
phase with the initial part of the
experiment by showing this little ramp
and the telencephalon habenula and the
habenula habenula
currents don't seem to get engaged until
after the lapse into passivity now this
is an example shocked fish right so what
you see here is the movements that are
overlaid on this current plot and you
know occasionally a fish would make an
exploratory tailwhip after the lapse
into passivity which is really the flat
part of the movement curve and so what
this is telling you is that the currents
really behave in a rather different
manner than what we were originally
expecting in that the active coping
phase may be driven by inputs from the
raphe or the feedback inputs from the
raphe into the empanada and this finding
holds even when we averaged across fish
and so here now on the left you see the
control condition averaged across five
fish as a function of time and this is
the average movement and you see that
the three currents in you know rapid
habenula have been used I've been in our
telencephalon today habenula those sort
of mirror each other from the duration
of the experiment and we're still
investigating what kind of drift would
explain the slowly ramp in the shocked
fish however you see that this trend
that I showed in the example holds which
is that the raphe to the habenula
currents seem to be engaged first
mediating what we think by correlation
with the active coping phase and the
teal and Cephalon today have been
habenula have any recurrence don't
engage and ramp up until after the lapse
into passive coping and so to really now
prove to you that these are two distinct
timescales I want to now show you the
same probability distribution of the
rapids that have been in the currents
now on the Left plotted as a function of
interaction strengths again this is in
logs and the gray and the red lines that
you seen here are the early part of the
experiment because they are now
color-coded by the time of the shocks
and you see that relative to the
baseline which is gray the red or the
early part of the shocks are not that
different but it's only later in the
experiment that the rapid they have been
earlier have been in the connections or
directed interactions strengthen lining
up exactly with the plot that I showed
you in the first half of the talk so
what this actually tells you is that
there are two distinct timescales at
play here
the early part of the athlete of the
experiment or the early part of the
behavior or the star the active coping
phase could be driven by rotations to
the current manner to the manifold in
the curves alone from the raf into the
habenula and the later part may be
driven by changes in the overall
connectivity or plasticity mechanisms
that control actual strengths of
projections from let's say in this case
from the raphe into the headband eula so
this is I'm replating what I showed you
before and then showing you again what I
showed you in the bottom part of the
curve before and I would like to return
to the question that we posed in the
beginning of the talk which is well what
circuit changes mediate the state
transition from active to passive coping
in the novel zebrafish and you know we
found two things in the first part of
the talk I told you that have been Euler
interactions strengthened with
persistent inescapable adversity and
unexpectedly the model popped out a
feedback interaction from the raphe into
the heaven EULA as having strengthened
the second part of the talk is you know
preliminary but we're trying to develop
this currents based decomposition
analysis that really richer roles of the
fear the telencephalon projections into
the heaven in LA and so we we think now
that the active coping phase is driven
by much faster changes to the manifolds
and then the later part of the
experiment or the later part of the
behavior which is passive coping or a
much slower transition is driven by
changes to the actual connectivity brain
wide or to connections to the di matrix
as predicted by our model so here are a
few conclusions of what I've told you
today right I hope I've convinced you
today that we are able to build these
multi-region RNN models that are capable
of generating normal dynamics consistent
with neural and soon behavioral data
from these types of behavioral
experiments in general but in this case
from the active passive coping stage
transition networks like this are able
to let us infer consistent directed
interaction matrices or the connectivity
matrices which reflect both inter area
and intra or within area connections and
we want to be able to figure out where
what motifs in these directors
interactions correlate with the
behavioral stage transition or state
changes finally we've begun this
manifold based analysis on the currents
of currents based decomposition as this
as a new method to suggest that early
and earlier and/or fast timescale and
slow time scale effects can actually be
teased apart by looking at currents in
this in this interesting way and so I'm
also presented preliminary results from
the habenula Raphael and Cephalon three
region are and then were currently
scaling this up to the whole three so
overall I think my lab is trying to pose
this type of multi-region potentially
brain wide RNN models that are
constrained from the on and the outset
from time series measurements obtained
empirically and working closely with
experimentalists as a viable alternative
to traditional correlation based
functional connectivity analysis methods
and so we're we're currently working on
the second manuscript and
dr. Matt Parekh is is the the Rockstar
postdoc who has been leading much of the
theoretical effort on this so with that
I'd like to thank you all for your
attention and again highlight the
efforts of Matt Parekh and communal
Spencer Salman the two key drivers of
the theoretical portion of this of this
work that I presented today I'd like to
thank Tyler benster and Erin Andelman
from the Karl Deisseroth lab for the
generosity you know intellectual as well
as experimental data and for the heroic
experiments that they've that they've
conducted I would also like to thank the
brain initiative particularly for their
support on support of this work without
them should have support in their faith
in our approach none of this work would
have been possible and so with that I'd
like like to thank you for your
attention
and if you know any motivated
individuals who would like to join a
diverse and young group in investigating
these types of questions about brain
wide mechanisms of behavioral state
transitions please point them in our way
thank you